um I want to play this which is a video
that I saw a long time ago and I always
wanted to [ __ ] IO and I think about
it quite a bit and it's very funny to me
and the other good thing is whenever I
put my [ __ ] forearm on this table the
wood between the between the wood and
the iron it pinches the hair of it and
it really pisses me off and that's a
good thing just so everybody knows I'm
so glad that that happens because it's
[ __ ] why wouldn't I be glad I love
when somebody [ __ ] post this [ __ ] out
of anyway magma ODIs it's called magma
otis and my favorite thing here is in
parentheses best live performance okay
it's not but also in a way it is this
guys singing is the way I want to say
first of all he's [ __ ] wearing just
something that the bad guys in Superman
who wear the Christopher Reeves movie
and his hair is has zero product in it
which is the best when somebody has zero
product in their hair
it's [ __ ] goddamn hilarious you have
to bro are you in this society put some
product in your hair okay because you
literally look like you [ __ ] stuck
one of his 1975 fingers into an outlet
and then when let's perform this video
how funny is it that this video is so
loud the way they uploaded it I have to
put on the bottom [ __ ] the littlest
volume otherwise it's too loud oh wow
this screenshot screenshot is [ __ ]
amazing but it is busting and if inta
seem darius i don't why this specialized
so much but
[Music]
Wow every time he takes the microphone
away he goes I guess sin daily assertive
hoo-hah
busting every time he takes the
microphone away he busts in his pants a
little bit
he busts in his [ __ ] Superman outfit
[Music]
busting dude dude he this is a tribute
to Otis Redding right this song is a
tribute to Otis Redding that this
[ __ ] French got what is this
legendary singer Christian Vander
killing it not always what is he German
what is this who knows it's a like
legendary singer Christian Vande or
killing it Christian van are bringing me
to tears singing a made-up language
about aliens and [ __ ] this is sublime is
it not a real [ __ ] language Wow
he's French
[Music]
I want to be I want to sing like this
and I will eye-fuck it so awesome
this guy's pure him he's pure him that's
why I that's why I was talked about you
got to get to the point where you're so
you that it's unreal it's a him no wow
look at him older that's [ __ ] serious
in de leus
that is so [ __ ] sin de leus he's 71
right now you know that makes me think
hora hora sin Darius this guy saw him
well you deserve some [ __ ] for real
let's go on because when you go on this
really kicks it up into high gear
[Music]
yeah
Wow
I've never been in love with a man
before but I'm in love with him for real
this is [ __ ] Cindy
[Music]
I just kind of really like to read
Wow
bro as in the area
this has to be a real [ __ ] let's look
at the comments out some of the stuck
that landing white let me look at the
hood he doesn't the end stuck that
landing
[Music]
or people clapping okay get some Wow
somebody writes so ugly and yet so
beautiful to see that's the best thing
that's the best dude when something's
bad and good it's absolutely the best it
is absolutely the best I always [ __ ]
say this
that's why coffee is the best because
it's not good but I keep drinking it
every day for some reason waiting for it
to be good and it's also kind of in a
way good that's why I like dumb silly
humor because it's good and also bad but
that's what makes it good yeah we
figured we don't need to [ __ ] do any
other thing anymore yay I got faint when
I did that um anyway dude Sindel eeeh
for real